all right chaos chaos oh where you from
originally where'd you grow up I was
born in San Pedro California and uh I
grew up right next to there Torrance
they call it South Bay that's pretty
much it tell me about your family you
had Mom and Dad um I was an only child
my dad's dead he he died in
2004 and uh my mom she's uh like some
Ultra militant Christian so I haven't
talked to her in like uh probably like
15 years how would you describe your
childhood
um I think it was I mean to me I think
it was regular you know I was always in
trouble when I was a kid so you know I
was always real hyper so I was always uh
military schools and you know and uh my
mom was like U pretty strict so I was
like uh I don't know it seemed like
there was always like some kind of
conflict you know and I be but I be with
my dad on the weekends and I was like uh
you know that was like the vacation for
me how far did you go to school
um high school and then I got locked up
when I was 15 and pretty much uh stayed
getting locked up till now how old you
now I'm 48
48 you've been in and out of prison in
and out of prison
um
uh I pretty much went from um go to like
the most
extreme uh pretty quick like in LA
County Jail they have this place called
the uh gang module it was the white gang
module it was in 3,400 Charlie row and
uh this is when it was pretty much a
death sentence to be in LA county if
you're white and uh you know the whites
there uh you know I don't know if people
know but we represent about 8% of the
prison population but we're responsible
for like 67% of the murders and you know
so so the politics get real thick you
know um but I started out there and then
uh some of my home boys were uh you know
mostly were their Riders and uh that's
when I started getting courted into the
ride so the gang life started early for
you started early I just pretty much
went from a kind of like a [__] up kid
from Torrance
to like strung
out uh worst of the worst California
gang member you know domestic teret all
this [__] you know um and ended up doing
most of my prison time in the
shoe um pelicon B I'm still active today
so like shoe is the uh solitary
confinment security housing in Pelican
Bay been in Pelican Bay twice uh corer
and
tachp uh new Fon 3 uh
B3 and uh where'd you get exposed to the
the whole gang see uh when I first went
to um County Jail when I was young and
uh back then I if you were white uh it
was [__] in there you like it was like
a third world country like we couldn't
have S all the whites and like would
walk around with socks and it it was bad
so the violence was there from the
beginning you know like everything is
[__] violence you know what I'm
saying like uh it's it mostly racial oh
for sure California even though you see
on TV it's like looks like this like
liberal Utopia but the racism is here in
California you know and it's it's real
you know um yeah but that yeah it's it's
all based on that as a member of the the
white gang do you have more problem with
the Mexicans or with the
blacks oh blacks for sure you know um
Mexicans too though you know um
but we we get problems to anybody though
you know what I mean we're known for
being short but like no no nobody really
wants the [__] extended [__]
conflict with us for
sure can you talk about some of the
crazy things you've been through in
prison um no names no names I can talk
about some things I guess you know um
like what you got to give me something
to go on from have you have you had to
uh take care of people that need taken
care of yeah um with my gang you have to
you have to stab
most really what you know to make it
look good you have to stab somebody for
each letter so you know that's three
stabbings right there you know um but
yeah
uh I stabbed nor old Fon uh earn my
earned my letter and [__] and uh got
courted into the ride and then made it
official but it never stops after that
you're always doing stuff after that you
know is there a way in prison to not get
involved in all that stuff
um I mean if you go if you go to prison
for I mean you go for low and you're on
like a low yard yeah but when you start
getting like threes and fours and even
the county jail like you don't really
have a choice you know especially if
you're white like um it's you know
you're going to constantly be targeted
like in uh if you don't fall within a
certain group then uh you know you're
pretty much just Cannon F you
know are you more comfortable in pris or
in the street man I hate being in and I
hate being in prison dude like you know
and all that time in the shoe man I I
really think it like [__] me up you know
cuz you know I probably did like 15
years you know um of like straight Shoe
Time and uh like it changes you dude
like you know what I mean it it [__]
changes you and you get you know
acclimated to that and you hit the
streets and then it's [__] weird dude
you know it's [__] weird and you got
a huge
[__] you know Grudge about it you
know what I'm saying like a huge Grudge
you know and it's it's hard to just you
know be whatever normal is you know what
I mean like um so that's like you know
you don't want to be in prison but you
know then again it feels familiar you
know like okay I know how to do this you
know what I mean I'm might you know get
I don't know how to do it but you know I
know how to do this you know you know
it's [__] up but it's true you
know um 1998 um I had a homeboy of mine
like he's a pretty famous dude from
South Bay his name was uh Ricky Thorp
and uh that that was my [__] boy and
uh I was only like 21 22 I just just got
into the [__] ride you know and uh he
was a rider all my HK you know when I
say Rider I mean Nazi low rider they
were Nazi low riders and [__] you know
and and um you know back then it was
[__] cool to be Nazi like our [__]
was I still think it is but people talk
a lot of [__] about my game but
um in the back of their mind they know
not the rise of [__] you know what I
mean and uh um but yeah he he R I looked
up to him and I pretty much got the
right cuz of them them cats and uh
anyway he he had a little disagreement
with this uh this girlfriend of his and
uh the the dude that was involved it was
like you know he was somebody more than
us you know and uh he ended up putting a
shotgun to this dude's chin the [__]
cop seen it he left the gun the guy got
busted so now now my homeboy like dude
if I go to back I'm going to get struck
out if uh I do go back they're going to
[__] kill me for getting this guy
busted and uh so you know pulls out [__]
and he's like you know so if we get
pulled over um I'm going to hold Court
in the street all right cool and we're
drinking and see people say [__] when
they're drinking so you know I didn't
think nothing of it but uh the next day
we were uh we were driving down the
street going to play ping pong all
things and uh torren PD [__] uh they
got behind us and pulled us over and
right here on like seov and Arington and
uh soon as they opened the door my
homeboy got out and just [__] fired
on these [__] cops dude and he [__]
them up because they kept trying to do
these little cop holds and grabs and
[__] and my home boom boom boom boom and
uh but then he went for it he had a [__]
on his back and the cops have it on
their side so they're faster you know
and uh he tried to go for it and as soon
as I seen him I was like in this little
mini blaze in the back and you know I
hit the deck and
then like probably about 30 shots and I
look up and uh my homeboy was on the
ground he had one his forehead he was
doing you know this whole thing the cops
ran hid behind their car and um uh yeah
they [__] aired my homeboy out do he
did just what he said you know he was
going to hold Court in street but then
after that you know in the the news and
the newspapers they said uh you know two
Nazi low riders tried to attack the cops
and one got killed so at that point in
my career like you know as far as like
heat from the government was insane you
know so like I was always that you know
like I lived toward my I couldn't go to
that City at all D if I couldn't pass
Western you know and uh you know and it
also got me a lot of chit with you know
IGI gang cops and [__] like that so
um yeah it was just a constant like
they're just trying to give you life you
know
constantly trying to get me with
something to remove me from the streets
you know didn't matter if I was doing
good I had dirty tests in 18 these dud
once you're a target for the government
they'll never [__] let you go dude
never and it don't matter if you're
doing good or whatever so you I mean to
me I think I'm just going to be me dude
I'm I'm a [__] criminal [__] gang
member I'm a I'm an enemy of the system
and [__] um and that's what I do good
and that's that's what I'm going to do
you know so you know I I read a lot of
Edward bunker books you know you know
who Edward bunker is I do he played Mr
Brown and Reservoir Dogs uh but he you
only see him at the coffee shop scene
but he writes all these prison books
where these dudes he wrote his first
book in San Quenton and um all his books
are like dudes in prison gets out tries
to do good and he's like [__] it I'm
just going to be who I am and ends in a
[__] shootout the end you know but uh
yeah Edward bunker it's my boy
do you have any regrets in your life um
I got two daughter I got two and
daughters man
um um they one lives in Germany right
now and one's in the Air Force um but uh
they think I'm a piece of [__] you know
like
[__] I mean I don't think they like
they call me and they like they try to
go through the motions and [__] but like
I wasn't there but I tell them that like
dude that's a good thing you should
thank me for that like any kind of
involing contact with me would have been
a downgrade like that would have hurt
you and like somehow some way you know
like and my mom raised them and they got
raised good and they speak like three
languages and [__] and they're good
girls and and because they're girls
girls always want their dads so they
still think like you know they really
think that like I I wasn't around cuz I
didn't like him or love him or like
something was wrong with him you know
they really think that you know but I
try to make him understand understand
that me stepping back was like the right
thing to do you know as long as my mom
had them they're still in the F you know
so you know I always tell them like what
do you think your daughters or people in
general don't understand about you yeah
um I'm an intense [__] dude like
um I have a tendency to go way over the
top about [__] like even like people
like if I think you're my friend you
know like I'm the dude that's want like
oh dude bumped into you at the store I'm
going to go kill him dude you know like
I I'm like that person you know and like
um and I have a tendency to expect that
in return and that's not feasible it's
not realistic people don't act and um
the other thing is I just don't like
[__] people you know like most people
are [__] fake
[__] it's you know you see it like um
you read a lot of books and you watch
YouTube and
you know uh David I you know there's the
sheele and there's the wolves and you
can really see it man like uh I think I
read too many books when I was in
Pelican Bay
CU I have like a theory or conspiracy
about everything you know I read a lot
of psychology and Mei and stuff like
that and but you see it man like um and
PE you know the news and everything and
people are just [__] robots man like
uh and if you got wolf Tendencies like
if you're any kind of free thinking you
know go out and get that [__] type of
person uh the system is designed to
remove you you know and uh that's why if
you got a record you're always going to
be on their radar because uh they don't
want you man they um no wolves in sheep
town you know
um and it's real man people are stupid
you know and they'll see something on TV
and um they'll repeat it and you know
like this politically correct stuff and
like you know people basally just watch
TV to know what to think and say or feel
you know without really knowing what the
[__] they're saying you know especially
about racism and you know [__] like that
you know I
mean Nazi what you know people consider
me I I mean I got sasus dude I'm real
about the the history of you know um the
Reich and uh all of that you know even
modern day stuff but uh racism is you
know a lot of is just I want to I think
it would be cool if there were white
people around 10 years from now and why
is that wrong to say if I was Black or
Mexican and I said that I would be
applauded for being into my culture you
know but because I'm white and I say
something like that I'm a racist you
know and uh I I hate the double standard
dude the double standard [__] pisses
me off you know so I don't know most
people just you know piss me off I think
I got some only child syndrome too you
know are you you this this black sheep
non-conformist attitude you have is that
something you inherited from your
parents I don't know I I was always like
do okay so I'm half Greek and then
German so um and my dad Greek he he he
was straight from Greece like a wet back
he he was working on a uh container ship
that cuz like when you're young a Greek
you know here your construction there
their industry is shipping all
youngsters work on ships and [__] like
the container ship so he was working on
it broke down New York to get repairs
and like him and two of his buddies jump
Shi and came back and he met my mom on
Sunset my mom was a waitress some coffee
shop on Sunset and boom bam you know but
but my dad side uh Greek what the [__]
are we talking about no I was just
asking if you inherited this this this
personality I don't know if you know
about Greek people but Greek people are
like super chill cool [__]
kind-hearted people you know what I mean
all you know I've never really met like
a [__] Greek that was a dick dude
like and they're they're not going to
get mad at their daughters for like
having a Mexican boy they're cool people
man you know and so my dad was always
real chill dude you know like but my mom
was just oh my god dude like like she
just and she's smart she's got a degree
from you and she's just think she's got
something like like to her Christianity
fixes everything dude and everybody know
knows that Christianity is fake none of
that happened dude you know what I'm
saying like it's not possible you know
it's I don't I don't believe you know
what I mean like um and uh you can't
just like like bring that up to fix
everything you know it's not realistic
dude you know what I mean like and uh
she was just on me dude like you know if
I [__] up like she had a big old belt
and I was constantly getting whipped and
[__] up and like you know she's a
female and I want you know so you know
females like to play mind games so I was
raised like d and I just I don't know
man it just built up like just a [__]
resent like just anger in me you know
like but I was always the kid that you
know like I like Darth Vader dude I
don't like Luke you know I mean like I
always go for those guys you know what
I'm saying like you like the darker yeah
those are my you know I mean so I I
don't know man I I don't know but you're
still active at this age I'm still
active you know there's a lot of stuff I
can't talk about like I don't want to
get killed dude you know my peers get
killed all the time dude you know you
know what I mean I don't know if my
daughter anybody realized but you know
it's [__] dangerous out here and you
know when I go to jail or prison it's
usually CU I never go for drugs it's
assaults and weapons you know and like
it's ridiculous to be out here and like
give somebody [__] for carrying a gun
dude because it's [__] dangerous out
here dude like Los Angeles is [__]
it's Los Angeles dude um people [__]
you know they'll pull their [__] out
before they [__] talk to you you know
and it happens all the time you know and
especially the lifestyle lead with you
know these gangs and these politics here
um you
know yeah it's real you know it's real
real but now this is what I do now so
like um I you didn't ask me but you know
like I right now I'm on the run I got a
power run for of scouting so I know I
got to go to jail and do a violation you
know um right now and uh I both mostly
make my money you know doing
fraud um
drugs um anything I get my hands on you
know basically but I like fraud cuz you
know the exposure is pretty like low you
know but um do you use drugs yeah I use
drugs i
crystal on the side that's that's that's
just just on the side you know it
started with Heroin I first did heroin
and the white gang module 3,400 H row
you know that was the first time I tried
heroin and I used to be a little tweaker
kid and but when you do
heroin like there's nothing like heroin
that's why they say once you're a heroin
addict you're a hero addict for life you
know and uh you know what happened here
is uh so I was a heroin adct for years
you know and uh but they started phasing
out the heroin and uh it was nothing but
fentol so you know there's going to be
times when you can't get to your heroine
and you're going to be sick but you know
you can get well with f all one time and
then that one time turned into a couple
days or three days and boom now you're
smoking Fentanyl and U it's 100 times
stronger than herin so you don't and you
know but yeah that's where I'm at now
you I smoke a lot of fent and you know
Crystal and you
know every other thing pretty much you
know You' been in love before oh yeah um
yeah like a month and a half ago my my
girlfriend died
um she uh sorry yeah um her name was
Jennifer she um she wasn't like my main
main girl but she was like the girl had
and she was real cool and she and she
[__] loved me I don't know why and uh
she was a real uh cool person and U but
she was she had a black belt
mtin but so she wasn't no pushover so we
used to get in some pretty big fights
but um she never did she didn't do
Fenton or nothing like that she smoked
Coke and uh I guess there's been a wave
of coke with fentol in it and she smokes
some and [__] died dude happens a lot
down here yeah and know it just happened
Long Beach she was living in Long Beach
and they kept her dead she was like
laying on her uh living room floor for
like about 6 hours waiting for the
corner to come CU I guess there was some
shooting somebody else got killed right
then and uh but that's like my last
image of her is is laying on that floor
you know your stomach bloats
up I I remember that like her stomach
was really bloated up dude and it
happened
quick weird [__] you know like what's
your biggest fear now um life
sends that's my biggest fear um my
biggest fear is
like because I got a lot of ongoing
beefs I got a lot of haters dude like um
the girls like me dude and the dudes
[__] hate me dude and it's always
been like that for me and um but some of
these dudes U beef him with you
know um they can have me killed you know
pretty
easily um so it's a constant chess
game um you know but
that's I don't know if you ever read 48
Laws of powers but like you define
yourself through your conflict and who
your enemies are you know it says if you
got little scrub ass enemies get rid of
them and get some better ones you know
the yeah um so but yeah there there's
always that
and then drugs of course you know I
could always die for that too you know
but I'm usually pretty careful with that
but yeah chaos what would you say is the
most important lesson you've learned in
your life
[__]
um just don't give a [__] dude just ask
a lot of questions and and do what the
[__] you want man because life is really
short and you're going to be so [__]
pissed when you die and you find out
there's not some magic Jew up there
Grant people wishes and and you said no
to a lot of cool things because of some
[__] ridiculous belief you know or or
what others um opinion of what you
should be or do and and you've lived
your whole life you know being somebody
else you know sometimes I'm like dude
[__] it I got to do a little time dude
but the time in between I've lived a
hundred
lifetimes like a square person would
live you know and so yeah so [__] it I
got to do some time sometimes but you
know the time in between is it's
actually kind of worth it
dude cuz it's a lot of girls and it's a
lot of DRS and it's a lot of [__] um
cool cars and gangster [__] going on and
like you get addicted to the scene
really you know but then there's people
look you look out here skid roll these
are the people that try to live that
life but couldn't hack it and uh but now
they just you know burnt all their [__]
out because they were trying to be a
drug out her Thug and nobody wants him
anymore and so they really ain't that
person so now they don't know what to do
they just stand on the corner like you
got a quarter bro you know hey this this
has been my name for the last six
months that's all you it's all you know
you know white person asking for a
cigarette you know so I don't know
that's how I think you know cuz you when
I had nothing I would get I have no
family [__] I get out with nothing I
would start boosting you could boost
Cosmetics from the um CVS's R AIDS you
get these you know right white strips
and fusion blades take them to the pis
of Border brush down they cash you out
you know um do that so much and I saved
and I got a little uh Acura uh Integra
boom I had my little whip once you got a
car here in California you're straight
you can make money and then kept doing
it kept doing it saved some more money
got all myo you got a little apartment I
had my peroy apartment and then my real
apartment and um but yeah I was taking
the bus to go boo I was going to school
during the day at Wild Tech I'd get off
get on the bus CVS Albertson's Walgreens
boo boom take it all call the uh the
fence casat me out and um yeah if I
didn't do that I wouldn't eat or you
know have clothes or nothing and uh and
I had to so I don't know is that a crime
I don't know you know what I'm saying it
was either that or [__] die so I I
don't know but yeah you can hustle man
you can you can Elevate yourself out of
that situation you know I believe but
then there's crazy people too that you
know they're really mentally [__] up
so I guess those people
don't
uh yeah all right chaos thank you so
much for sharing your story you're
welcome man appreciate
you